[Applause]
[Music]
Turkmenistan is a country yes we didn't
make it up you may not have heard of it
but believe me it does exist
and you should be more worried about it
than you think you remember a Ralph
Wiggum from well tech menaced an is like
the Ralph Wiggum of countries and before
we go on here's a disclaimer absolutely
everything you're going to see in this
video is real we didn't make anything up
we're not even exaggerating it's a
hundred percent true
[Music]
you see this country is about to be host
to the stupidest ecological catastrophy
in history yeah that's right stupid
basically in 1971 the state sends
geologists to look for natural gas in
the desert and they came up with a
brilliant idea of building an extraction
platform right above an underground cave
what could go wrong
well the platform sank leaving a crater
the size of a soccer field a crater from
which methane gas started pouring out so
what did they do to stop the leak well
if you found a gigantic crater that's
gushing our natural gas what wouldn't
you do well yes that's what they did
someone came up with a brilliant idea of
setting it on fire since then the so
called Gate of Hell is still burning and
it doesn't look like it'll die out
anytime soon and you might be thinking
what are they doing now with that gate
of hell is it a tourist attraction is it
a restricted area to keep the public
safe
well no the Gate of Hell is used for
this
yes the man you see driving as if he
would michael schumacher himself is none
other than the current dictator of
Turkmenistan a man called Gurbanguly
Burton a meadow and yes his name is a
total tongue twister I'm not sure if I'm
getting it right is indeed driving a
rally style around the gate of hell as a
way of creating political propaganda the
Turkmenistan dictatorship is truly
unique in history but you might be
thinking okay well the basically insane
dictator I mean what exactly is new is
this the reason that we should care
about Turkmenistan Simon well no there's
much more to it I mean think about it
the existence of that gate of hell
proves one thing this country has gas
and we aren't talking about normal
reserves here Tech Menace dawn has the
fourth largest natural gas reserves in
the world about 10% of the world's gas
is in Turkmenistan so as you can imagine
Turkmenistan's potential is enormous and
best of all it's a potential that can be
exploited to give you a better idea
Russia and Qatar currently export the
most gas in the world
[Music]
Aoife chooses Russia and Qatar to host
2018 and 2022 World Cups as you can see
having gasps means having friends all
over the world
what's more Europe has been looking for
alternative gas supplies for years in
order to curb its dependence on Russia
what's more while Russia's gas reserves
are estimated to last 58 years and
Qatar's for 141 jackman Aston has gas
reserves for the next 317 years and at
this point is anyone else remembering
the teachers at school that told them
that gas was gonna run out anytime soon
but the fact that Turkmenistan has gas
for more than 300 years means two things
one that indeed they have a lot of gas
but also that they aren't exploiting it
as much as they could in fact it's
completely under exploited so such a
country has everything it needs to be
swimming in abundance especially if we
consider that it has a population of
less than 6 million people basically
these people shouldn't really have to
worry about money unfortunately this
isn't the case most of the people are
poor and they suffer under the
dictatorship
why did Turkmens remain so poor what on
earth is happening in this country well
today we're answer all of these
questions but first a bit of history
[Music]
craziest dictators in history check -
dawn is a dictatorship but is there
anything worse than your own country
being a dictatorship well yes and that's
for the president to believe that he's
Kanye West and torture all Hartman with
his flow
[Music]
so it's not just that there's no freedom
of speech it's not bad enough that
citizens are obliged to praise their
leader they also have to dance to his
music by now you may be wondering how
you've never heard about tak mana stone
before but you should have feel bad if
the world were a hotel tucked menaced
and hung up it's Do Not Disturb sign a
long time ago the Turkmen dictatorship
doesn't want anyone to know what is
happening in the country that's how it's
been since it became independent in 1991
in fact no one knows for sure how many
gas platforms there are in the country
or if they actually work no one knows
the extent of the road infrastructure
practically the only freely distributed
information coming out of this country
is its presidents music but if you think
that you should be wary of president
burden more medow it's because we
haven't spoken of his predecessor Sabah
more at nya solve or as he wanted to be
called Turkmen bassy which means the
leader of all Turkmen nice of was first
secretary of the Turkmen Communist Party
during the Soviet era from 1985 right up
until his death in 2006 he was the most
senior leader of Turkmenistan after the
USSR disintegrated in 1991 he still
managed to hold on to the country's
presidency far from allowing the country
to evolve towards democracy
nyah soft proclaimed himself president
for life and Turkmenistan consolidated a
dictatorship that was isolated from the
world's an authoritarian regime without
any respect for human rights my
self-imposed occults based on his
extravagant personality his favorite
hobby was to build huge golden statues
all over Turkmenistan regarding foreign
policy he was more discreet my Assaf
proclaimed tech - Dawn's eternal
neutrality dagwon bases logic was if he
leaves everyone alone no one is gonna
mess with him and until now that
strategy has actually worked pretty well
for all of its dictators
it went so well that naya selves ordered
the construction of a gigantic monuments
to neutrality in the capital city of
ashgabat and at the top they placed a 12
meter golden statue of tockman bassy
but not just any statue no a statue that
rotated in order to always be facing the
Sun now they think that Naya saw was
just a superficial guy obsessed with
gold being a communist dictator that's
kind of standard the worst was when he
got emotional then he became a poet he
got so much into it that he wrote a book
of poems that Raja nama
the book of the soul so far writing a
book is pretty standard for dictators to
some right the little red book and Naya
saw of wrote well look of the soul but
the thing is that every turkmen was
forced to learn this book by heart it
was essential in the educational system
and in everyday life you'd be getting
your driver's license and suddenly the
examiner would say section 4 page 155
you may have been able to drive better
than Michael Schumacher but you either
answered the Battle of Dandan Akron or
failed instantly but this wasn't enough
an ass off so he had to torture us with
this as well tech menaced on is the
place par excellence of impossible and
improbable monuments Turkmenbashi
himself ordered the construction of this
statue of his book a gigantic version
that opens and closes every afternoon
dictating ourselves eccentricities had
no limits he also changed the name of
the days and months January was called
turkmenbashi in his honor and April was
after his mother durdane Sultan
September was renamed Raja nama after
his book now you may be thinking but hey
with such a North Korean style dictator
why didn't he bequeath the presidency to
his son Murat well seat Murat was so
useless the tag man Basie preferred his
dentist as his successor over his own
son because yes current presidents
baramura medow really was a dentist his
entire life and now he's worse than a
toothache for all Turkmens
[Music]
however his first moves as president
were somewhat hopeful Turkmenistan's
calendar returned to normal
knowing the original was no longer
mandatory he even took down some of Naya
Psalms golden statues there was also
progress in the economy for decades the
only thing Turkmenistan could exploit
was cotton the restful is a subsistence
economy
the Soviets searched persistently the
natural gas and of course they found it
but the results weren't significant
however in 2006 Turkmenistan found its
lifeline and of course you might be
thinking it sounds like everything was
starting to work out for the country
dictator Turkmen bassy was dead the new
president seems half normal and they
discover a giant cache of gas so well
what could go wrong well the usual
Turkmenistan's dictator just built a
huge golden statue of himself riding a
horse what can I say don't ask me what
they're eating in Turkmenistan or what's
happening in the presidential palace
that makes its leaders turn into a cross
between King miters and Goldfinger but
these dudes they are not normal true
Berdimuhamedow hasn't reached Turkmen
Basie's level just yes but he's not far
off and he's also given himself a
nickname Berdimuhamedow
is our codec which means the protector
so you may be wondering what did this
guy do with all of the gas well let's
find out Dragan to fuel tech - dawn is
basically a desert the 10th largest
desert in the world the Karakum desert
occupies 60% of its territory in roma
that name Karakum because is there
anything worse than your country being a
desert well yes that's for your
president you dedicate a song to it and
for you to have to clap and dance along
to it like there's no tomorrow
I don't know about you guys but I would
promote the guy in green to be a
minister the good thing is the tech
menace dawn has natural gas half of the
gas that Turkmenistan currently produces
is for its own consumption the other
half of course is exported there are two
ways to export natural gas two thirds of
the world's gas trade is done through
pipelines the remaining third is done by
ships thanks to liquefied natural gas
these ships are called gas carriers and
they transport liquid gas at a very low
temperature seventy-five percent of the
global LNG market moves through the
Pacific with its main destinations being
Japan China South Korea and India but
here's where the problems begin for tech
manastar main one is that it has no
access to the ocean so liquefying gas
isn't an option therefore they can only
use gas pipelines and obviously to build
pipelines you need investments as you
can imagine in a country with such a
wild dictatorship where the political
elite has plenty of room for corruption
there's no transparency or legal
certainty so there's no one willing to
invest faced with this scenario which
country do you think has shown the most
interest in Turkmenistan while that
would be China which is also a
dictatorship and understands how to deal
with these types of countries the red
dragon showed up in Turkmenistan as soon
as it discovered how much gas they had
the letter of introduction was to rein
cash on the country fresh money for the
arcattack swims in exchange for the
site's exploitation and the construction
of a 1,800 kilometer gas pipeline
between Turkmenistan and the Chinese
border
[Music]
when this pipeline started operating it
provided China with more than a third of
the gas that it consumed but since then
China's demand has tripled
this means that gastrin tech mana stone
now represents 12 percent of the gas
that the Asian John requires in any case
Turkmenistan is still the main country
from which China buys natural gas the
problem is that it looks like all the
gas that China is taking isn't really
helping the Turkmen accounts all
analysts agree that the gas is helping
the government pay back all of the loans
that the architect dictatorship once
received then there's another problem
whatever money arrives the dictator
spends entirely his commitment Steve
diversify in the economy in boosting
tourism as two major milestones the
first was to build the largest airport
in Central Asia whopping 2.4 billion
euros have been spent on this Airport
which has a capacity of a 17 million
travelers to give you a comparison this
is roughly the same volume as that of
Tel Aviv's Airport
the milestone is this daughter's pretty
linear gas t gas initiative Namira a
firm net registrar super seat Italy if
we disturb Latin America shall on yoga
stay
Berdimuhamedov thoughts if I have a
desert sand I want tourists well what
can I do
well the communist version of Las Vegas
of course the problem is that the
Turkmen dictator forgot a minor detail
and it's that in order to have tourists
you have to provide visas which they
aren't willing to do so what's the
result
all those hotels are practically empty
the highest occupancy they reach is 30%
so as tourism project isn't as
successful as expected and his latest
gamble is the organization of sporting
events five billion dollars have been
spent on a macro spaced host the
well-known Asian martial arts tournament
but the dictatorship has already moved
forward to secure other upcoming events
maash tabata warded 2021 track cycling
world championships by UCI in fact we
have footage of how Akkad AG convinced
the International Cycling Union
President Emeritus mr. Pierson a beard
over neuron national R&D in the humid
paso de sole product eudaimonia reduce
trade imbalance here Kesava state japan
sedan nation relative coca tea be honest
be a human persona nisonger muppet now
Berdimuhamedow
is ready to go to the Olympic Games
basically Turkmenistan has a lot of gas
a part of which is being channeled to
China at a very good price and the money
that comes in is basically spent by
arkad AG but don't think he spends it
all 23 billion from Turkmenistan has
accumulated in accounts in Germany the
only reason the people of tec-9s town
should be optimistic is the energy
transition how long the dictatorship
will last that's hard to know but all
the signs indicates that the world will
want more gas in the medium-term Europe
for example would be delighted to have
more access to gas to reduce its
dependence on Russian gas they wouldn't
be above making pacts with the
dictatorship we've already seen all
about that in our video about Azerbaijan
but again Turkmenistan's biggest problem
is its geographical situation building a
pipeline onto the Caspian Sea is the
most direct option to reach Europe but
that would put it in the path of
Azerbaijan which wants to use its own
pipelines to sell its gas to Europe not
facilitate the sale of Turkmen gas and
Russia and Iran wait make building this
gas pipeline through the Caspian easy
in other words Turkmenistan would either
have to go through Iran which with the
issues of US sanctions isn't an option
or go through Russia but then Europe
would continue to depend on the Kremlin
for its gas
[Music]
based with the scenario apart from the
Chinese pipeline the only option that
seems viable is the tapi pipeline but
well what is tapi very simply tech
menaced an Afghanistan Pakistan and
India
[Music]
ten billion dollars invested to export
an amount similar to what Turkmenistan
currently sells to China forty-two
percent of the gas would be for Pakistan
another forty two percent for India and
Afghanistan would keep the remaining 16
percent the idea seems good and we'll be
watching to see if it actually works
it will also make a nice change to see
Afghanistan exporting something other
than drugs and jihadists the pipeline
would be a true boost for the Turkmen
economy but we have to wonder if that
money will really reach the people or if
Berta mow a meadow will just keep
spending it but here's a question for
you do you think Turkmenistan will jump
on the energy transition train or all
the dictatorship continue to ruin it can
you think of the project that the gas
money should be spent on and further
which architects song do you like the
best the tech Venice stone rap or the
Karakum desert tell me what you think in
the comments in the meantime don't
forget that we release new videos every
week so please subscribe to this channel
click on the bell so you don't miss any
updates if you like this video please do
give it a thumbs up and I'll see you
next time if you want to learn more
about politics and world affairs and
here's some more of my lovely voice come
check out the reconsidered podcast where
we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider at WWE consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast